what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime opera and meliodas the new
king of leonis is back meliodas has
finally appeared in the seven deadly
sins sequel the four knights of the
apocalypse and our new protagonist
percival just got to meet him face to
face after the recent reveal of bond's
son lancelot the return of meliodas just
made the current arc in the sequel that
much more interesting and not only is
melioda's back but he is still the same
carefree and fun-loving legend that he
always has been even after all this time
he is still the same old meliodas and
his cooking is still absolutely terrible
this was awesome we need to talk about
it if you guys enjoy our seven deadly
sins and four nights of the apocalypse
content and you want us to keep it going
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with that youtube
algorithm and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet don't forget that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
but very important way of supporting the
channel here on youtube now a quick
thank you to rush royale for sponsoring
this video rush real is a really cool
mix of a tower defense game and a card
game in which you defend your fortress
from enemy attacks you summon your
heroes level them up and you can even
merge them to make stronger units it's
super easy to get started and that's
what i love about it within a few
minutes of downloading the game i was
already playing strategizing and having
a ton of fun although the game is very
easy to get into there's still a ton of
strategy that goes into it and the game
becomes super fast paced and exciting
almost as soon as you start playing my
favorite part is the ability to battle
against other players in real time both
pvp and co-op this is honestly so fun
and addicting and i found myself playing
game after game and trying out new
strategies every time you can even join
a clan or create your own team and then
compete for a top spot in the rankings
install rush royale for free using my
links in the description or scan the qr
code on screen you can use the special
promo code y9bz-2jzg
to get an exclusive bonus master chest
with gold a set of cards and magic dust
which can be exchanged for legendary
cards these rewards are available for a
limited time only so check it out right
now link in the description finally this
video will of course contain four nights
of the apocalypse manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so in the previous chapter
the badass legend known as lancelot
decided to straight up teleport percival
and the others into leonis and then he
casually promised them to take them to
meet the king of leonis himself which as
we know is none other than meliodas i
admit that it was kind of weird to see
lancelot just transporting them all to
leona's after that whole journey that
they had to go through but i definitely
get why it all happened this way
percival and the others were undergoing
a sort of test because lancelot wanted
to make sure that percival really was
one of the four nights of the apocalypse
before taking him to see meliodas and
now that all the crewmates have been
recruited and percival's powers have
been revealed it is time to take the
story to the next level by introducing
major players like meliodas these last
few chapters seemed incredibly fast
paced especially compared to some of the
arcs and chapters from the past but i
think that's a good thing we are now
more than 50 chapters into the sequel
manga so it makes sense to turn things
up a notch and reintroduce major fan
favorite characters from the original
like meliodas i expect that the plot
will start moving quickly from here on
out a lot of major developments and
reveals are coming soon and i can't wait
to see what happens next the latest
chapter starts off with percival and the
gang being in a state of awe after
arriving at such a large and thriving
city most of these guys have never even
seen such a large city with a big castle
and all sorts of other buildings and
they need some time to take it all in
and i mean that makes sense if you're
from a small medieval town and you've
never even seen a big city and i don't
mean in real life but not even in
pictures or on tv because there's no
such thing as pictures and tv in the
middle ages then yeah when you suddenly
find yourself teleported in the midst of
a big city you're bound to be a bit
shocked by the whole experience lancelot
then tries to take everyone into the
castle to meet meliodas but the castle
guards tell him that meliodas has just
left the castle in order to go party
lancelot isn't even surprised by this
and he tells the others that they should
go kill some time before the king
returns now when reading the chapter at
this point i was convinced that we were
going to get trolled and that we
wouldn't get to meet meliodas in this
chapter i thought that the whole
meliodas is out of the castle thing was
going to be an excuse for not showing
him yet but thankfully i was wrong
because we did get to see the return of
the king but more on that later percival
decides to just go around for some
sightseeing and he ends up accidentally
bumping into old man dreyfus who is
trying to carry a bunch of boxes from
henriksen's clinic to the boar hat bar
dreyfus who is in his 60s at this point
seems to have pulled his back so
percival decides to carry the boxes for
him while at the same time healing his
back using one of his chibi percivals we
also get to see old man hendrickson
briefly as he comes to check up on
dreyfus and while i admit that these
guys were not among my favorite
characters from the original i do
appreciate it whenever we get to see the
old characters returning in the sequel
as principal is attempting to find the
boar hat bar he comes across someone
whom he believes to be a blonde boy of
about his age the boy says that he works
for the boar hat bar and the boxes that
percival is carrying are intended for
him the boy then explains that the boar
hat is a famous tavern that serves fine
drinks from all over britannia and the
boy proceeds to show percival the way to
the tavern the boy also asks percival
about his sword dragon handle and
percival explains that it's a piece of
the coffin of eternal darkness he also
says that he and his friends took the
piece from some bad guys because if the
bad guys had been able to gather up all
the pieces then there would be some big
trouble while reading this i couldn't
help but facepalm because percival is
telling someone he literally just met
about the fact that he is carrying a
piece of the coffin of eternal darkness
right there out in the open if this
young 3000 year old blonde boy had been
a bad guy then percival would have just
placed a massive target on his own back
luckily we know that this blonde boy is
none other than our boy meliodas himself
and as they arrive at the tavern we get
to see the third version of the boar hat
bar the bar is now on the ground and not
on the back of a giant bore but it still
has the same boar hat bar aesthetic
complete with a statue of hawk on the
roof when meliotis explains that he
actually owns this tavern percival is
surprised that a kid his age would
already be a tavern owner but he doesn't
think too much about it because meliotis
offers to cook him a meal and percival
happily accepts because he hasn't eaten
since this morning big mistake percival
big mistake melioda serves percival
deboer hat's special pudding and
although it looks great when percival
tastes it he almost dies i mean he
literally passes out and when he wakes
up he finds himself in bed with meliodas
standing over him percival looks like
he's having the biggest hangover ever
and honestly as corny as this running
joke about meliotis's terrible cooking
is this little detail made me feel so
nostalgic and so i liked it a lot
percival then notices that meliodas
called him by name and he asks him how
does he know the name percival meliotis
explains that he recognizes the scratch
on percival's helmet and the oroboros
brooch on his cape meliotis knew
percival's grandpa but he never thought
that vargaz's grandson would turn out to
be one of the four knights of the
apocalypse percival jumps up on the bed
and he demands to know how this blonde
kid knows his grandpa and how he knows
about the four nights of the apocalypse
and that is when the tavern keeper
finally introduces himself as meliotis
the king of leonis and that is how this
funny nostalgic and heartwarming chapter
ends
man this chapter didn't really have any
action or drama but i honestly loved it
i love how they brought meliota's back i
love how percival thought that he was
just like a kid his age and i absolutely
love the fact that despite becoming the
king of a powerful kingdom our boy
meliotis hasn't changed a bit i imagine
that he's still hanging out and drinking
at the tavern whenever he can he's
probably still perving on elizabeth and
then he probably throws in some
statesmanship stuff here and there
honestly just seeing meliotis trying to
balance being a king and also being his
normal crazy self would probably make
for a hilarious mini arc
but all the warm and fuzzy stuff aside
there are some big questions that emerge
from this chapter first up how does
meliotis know percival's grandpa vargaze
was a holy night of camelot so there's
no obvious reason why meliotis the king
of leones would be familiar with him and
yet meliodas clearly knows him well
enough to know the name of his grandson
percival which is not necessarily the
type of information that you would know
about some random night that you met at
a diplomatic conference or something and
then there's that oroboros connection
the oroboros is of course meliotis's own
tattoo symbol and vargaze also happens
to have that symbol although a different
variation of it on his brooch my
thinking is that meliodas knew vargaze
pretty well and he probably also knew
about the plan to hide percival away on
god's finger i mean i'm just speculating
but i feel like all of this must be
related to king arthur and how arthur
went from being the character we knew in
the original series to a ruthless
villain my guess is that whatever
happened to arthur must have happened
around the same time that percival was
taken to god's finger and it's possible
that percival is connected to all of
this and that he was hidden away so that
he would be protected from arthur this
also means that percival could be the
key to ultimately defeating arthur or at
least turning him back to normal and
that brings me to my next question what
does meliodas plan to do with the four
knights of the apocalypse clearly he is
extremely interested in finding them and
that is why he sent lancelot to find
percival but why exactly is he looking
for them is it because the four knights
of the apocalypse are really going to
destroy the world or is it because they
hold the key to arthur's fall from grace
and maybe arthur wants to get rid of
them because they pose a threat to him
all of these are really interesting
questions and i get the feeling that we
are about to learn a lot more crucial
information in the next few chapters
finally is meliotis going to play a
bigger role in the sequel or will he
just play a temporary side role like
gother did earlier in the story
personally i think that melioda's
playing a bigger role would be a cool
development because it would definitely
motivate fans of the original who still
haven't checked out the sequel to
finally check it out i know it's hard to
have someone as overpowered as meliodas
fighting alongside a brand new hero like
percival who is still only discovering
the extent of his power but raising the
stakes in terms of power wouldn't be
such a bad idea because again i feel
like a lot of fans of the original want
to see the kind of insane battles that
we saw in the original series but we are
still of course only on chapter 51 of
the sequel the original had over 300
chapters so we have to brace ourselves
that said having someone like melioda
step in for at least a little while and
impress everybody with his exceptional
demon power would be extremely epic
let me know what you guys think are you
as hyped as i am that meliodas is back
and did you like the fact that he is
still basically the same guy or would
you have preferred it if he had changed
more over the years what do you think
meliotis's relationship with percival's
grandpa was and what are his true
intentions with the four knights of the
apocalypse finally is meliodas about to
become a regular in the sequel or is
this just a temporary situation don't
forget to leave your feedback down in
the comments below if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
seven of these sins and four nights of
the apocalypse content on the channel
don't forget to leave a like it only
takes a second but it helps a lot and if
you're new here or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications it seems
like a small thing but subscribing
actually helps me out a lot on youtube
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
uproar as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys